d live is a live streaming platform
created to empower creators and reward
viewers that's you
I've been streaming on July before a
month now and it's been absolutely
fantastic everyone in the community has
been so welcoming okay it's been nothing
but smiles and laughs I love how
everyone in the community is so excited
about the platform and getting other
people into it as well so I definitely
recommend your streaming Oh deal I'm now
for you the viewer d-lab is rewarding
you more than ever before baby other
platforms they just spam a bunch of ads
very anti viewer D live completely
opposite very welcome viewer zero live
rewards you simply for watching
simply for chatty simply for supporting
streamers D live is launching a brand
new treasure chest how does this
treasure chest work you might ask the
more viewers engage
Shaq in donating the faster you will
unlock the chest and the faster that
chest gets burst baby the more viewers
will be rewarded to show my appreciation
my deep and utmost love I'll be
streaming on may 18th and let's burst
some chests baby this is during the D
live super fans festival to celebrate
you guys download the D live app now and
I'll see you guys on May 18 I think it's
been really fun to engage live with you
guys it's bringing in a whole new
perspective and idea so thanks for
everyone that joined me so far now let's
just get on with the video
I broke my balls
[Music]
that's right everyone it's time for me
to finally come clean and share one of
my most embarrassing stories of my life
and you might think to yourself oh I've
broken my balls too
it really hurts when you smash them oh
that's nothing
that's nothing sorry now technically I
didn't break my balls okay I just need
the titles to be consistent but let me
tell you what happened and he might
change your money
it might make you go I don't know what
pain is what that man experienced that
was pain
he didn't just break his a hat he also
broke his balls and he broke my heart
by listening to this story so let's just
jump into it I was 14 years old and I
woke up I did what anyone that has balls
do when they wake up you look you look
at that yeah I looked out on my boss and
I noticed hmm that's a bit weird the
other one is like three times four times
maybe larger than the other one
hmm that's a big but of course I didn't
think about him more than night why
should I but then as the day went on it
was sort of lingering in the back of my
mind you know what maybe it isn't
supposed to be so much bigger has it
always been that much bigger maybe I
just never noticed
maybe I'm just you know girls some girls
have this different proportion at
boobies maybe I'm a disproportionate
ball kind of guy you know it's not great
news it's nothing what I saw what do you
want to wake up realizing but that's
what I thought at leaves but then after
a while I realized I need to confront
this this is not normal okay so I did
what any person would have done if
there's something wrong with your balls
you show them to your dad and obviously
that's very humiliating already you
don't want to show your balls to your
dad at least I don't
I think the only context you're allowed
to show your balls to your diet is in
the sauna and now I think that's it
that's the only context or if your ball
is bigger than the other one of course
so I showed my I was freaking out okay I
was super worried about what was wrong
with me
you know worst possible scenarios is
running in your head
not like oh do I have cancer or Oh am I
good something really bad happened it
was oh my god am I gonna live with this
proportion that balls my entire life I
was freaking out I showed my balls to my
dad and he you know whenever you're
worried about something the most
reassuring thing that you can get back
from someone is obviously when they make
this face hey Dad can you please look at
my balls please and make sure it's
nothing bad right I'll never forget that
face worse than any disappointment
realize my camera isn't really focused
so obviously he didn't think it was fine
what am i sharing this so we we booked
an appointment with the doctor and I
think they let us in pretty quickly I
don't know if that's health care in
Sweden it's good or if they thought oh
like oh that's not that's really bad
well we'll need to get this guy into the
hospital but I remember this hospital
visit unfortunately very very very
clearly because it was painful a very
painful experience I basically had to go
into this room and I remembered so
clearly they had like brown tiles and
white walls just like hard surfaces
everywhere and there was this bed in the
middle of the room that it wasn't really
you know like those hospital beds then
you lay down on kind of like this just
imagine 14 or all mean like this
okay I'm laying down like this
I'm freaking out my dad is sitting next
to me and in comes this doctor and the
thing is like that what really bothers
me about these things is that no one
tells you what the courtesy is you know
in school they teach you about math they
teach you by a history they teach you
about science all these completely
useless things but no one teaches you
what to do when you have to present your
balls to a doctor all right here's a
question that no one teaches you in
school when you're supposed to present
your balls to someone do you give them
the courtesy of lifting up your song it
would make sense right I remember going
I remember God watch my sharing that and
hidden the doctor just going on put that
away let me get in there
so he started croaking I'm alone and
obviously that's not a very good feeling
I'm already humiliated and I had this
guy just going treating my boss like
it's some sort of thing that you poke I
don't know what kind of things do you
poke but he wasn't sure I guess he
really wanted to make sure it wasn't
something really bad so he wanted some
expertise his help and I'm pretty sure
he knew it was fine okay because I'm
pretty sure he just wanted to humiliate
me even farther so not just two more
doctors came in three more doctors came
in and one of them happened to be a very
attractive lady which is like the worst
thing you could ever have to someone
just poking or just looking I would
rather like she poked and just looked so
there I was in this cold room with my
dad next to me and I assumed they was
equally painful for him just think
doctors poking away now they concluded
okay we need to get the Bulls and so I
got an appointment about a week later
again same dilemma this time I was alone
my dad wasn't with me I wish it was
honestly for the better there was no
doctor in the room when I was sent in
there as well so and I know he's gonna
check out my balls
so again
no one teaches in this school am I
supposed to just take off my pants and
wait for him pay less and be like hey
I'm ready doctor
or do I wait to take off my pants I took
off my pants and I realized that's
really weird
can you imagine just coming in and some
oh hey doctor I'm ready poked away this
time they just used some sort of scanner
I don't know exactly what it was it
wasn't that it wasn't painful at all
this time maybe it's one of those
experiences that once you've done it
once it's not that bad I like to think
of it that way at least link what
doesn't kill you make you stronger
at least now if someone needs to inspect
my balls I can I can do it proudly but
they concluded it was just my blood
vessel in my balls had expanded dad-like
became larger so that was it that's the
story of how my balls are slightly
larger than average nobody baby boy now
I want the moral of this story to be you
know this is obviously a very
embarrassing experience but I also
consider myself very lucky to have balls
I think anyone that I have balls feel
very privileged to have them not that
then I'm not discriminating against
anyone without balls just let that be
clear I'm just saying I'm very happy to
have my balls what was the point of this
video I'm very lucky to have balls I'm
very lucky to have my point I'm very
lucky to be healthy but I'm not
discriminating against anyone okay and
also as some painful and embarrassing
this experience once it's something that
I can look back at and laugh at and not
just cringe into oblivion so if you have
any issues with your balls go and get
your balls checked
go show your balls to your dad anything
you got to do just do it because it's
better to find out you know I was lucky
that it was nothing but it's better to
find out these things sooner and if
there's any message I want to send out
there it is that just that show your
balls to your dad that's really the only
message of this video and I really hope
this helps people I'm doing this so I
can help other people I've actually had
my balls checked three times which is
three times too many
[Music]
now four times
why does these things happen to me
what's breaking my ass not enough I
think I shared enough about this
experience but I do feel better I gotta
say this is very therap etiquette for me
thank you for listening and I see you
next time
that's the story of how my balls are
slightly larger than average
[Music]
what you never played toupper simulator
you know it's fun right I'm not supposed
to give my opinion
but give it a try and then you can tell
me if it's good or not not convinced yet
okay I'll cut you a deal
the game is available for free and
that's a great price
[Music]